cabinet office minister michael gove
excited to speak to him this morning
joins us now hello to mr gove always a
pleasure thank you for joining us
what restrictions are the government
introducing today has it actually been
decided yet has it actually been decided
yet
yes it has the the prime minister will
be announcing the the full package
to the house of commons later uh but
as has been reported in the media it
will be the case that there will be
a new restriction so for example uh when
it comes to
uh to eating out to socializing then it
will be the case that establishments
uh will close at 10 um and we will have
a rule that it is table service
only but there'll be more details that
the prime minister will spell out
and again one of the points that he'll
make is that
no one wants to to do these things no
one wants to take these steps
they are reluctant steps that we're
taking but they're absolutely
necessary because as we were reminded
yesterday and as you've been reporting
the rate of infection is increasing the
number of people going to hospital is
increasing
and therefore we need to act
when were the decisions taken and by
whom
well decisions like this is taken by
cabinet committees of course i
i can't go into the the details of which
committee meets when but
in essence uh a package of advice was
put to ministers
that package was prepared by uh the
authoritative medical and scientific
advisors
who are there to help the government to
make these decisions
ministers look at uh what might be
considered wise
then we agree and then of course this
package is put
to the house of commons so it was a
cabinet
decision um talk to me about whether
people should be working
from home again now if they can
yes there is going to be a shift in
emphasis and
uh one of the things that we are going
to emphasize is that if it is possible
for people to work from home then we'd
encourage them
to do so um now it's important to stress
that there are many
many many roles which can't be performed
from home
there are people in manufacturing in
construction in retail
and in other roles will be recognized
that's simply impossible and that's why
we have worked
to make sure that you can have uh
covered secure
workplaces um and we need to balance
obviously
the need to ensure that people can
continue to work and indeed critically
continue to go to school and to benefit
from education
against taking steps to try to reduce
the virus which is why if we can
uh limit or appropriately restrain
social contact that's what we're trying
to do
um you will know our viewers may not
know that the government aimed to have
of whitehall staff uh back in the office
by the end of this month which is i
think what eight days away is that still
the plan
no um one of the things that we sought
to do was of course
to encourage people to be back at work
um and we were staging a process whereby
people would come back into work
um in whitehall and elsewhere um but
i've been in discussion
with the uh the permanent secretary um
at the cabinet office and one of the
things that we recognize
is that in the circumstances if we can
help people to work from home
we will but if people do need to be in
the office then we will
make sure we have make sure that they
can be as safe as possible
are these new restrictions and admission
of uh failure
uh by the government's approach i'm
thinking particularly as you'll know the
eat out to help out scheme looks a bit
um
silly now really
no i don't think so um i i think it's
the case that uh
we have to react to uh an increase in
the spread of the virus
and of course the steps that we took in
order to help the economy during
august i think were were welcome but we
need to recognize
uh that there are now some restrictions
that need to be put in place
but i should stress that it will be the
case that uh hospitality venues will
remain open
um but we're just making it clear that
it's table service only
and closing at 10 and these are measures
that have been
introduced in some parts of england we
hope that they'll now be
introduced and monitored across the
united kingdom
um and as i say you know it's not a step
that anyone wants to take
but we think that it's a proportionate
response given what we've been told
about the spread of the virus
and of course a stitch in time saves
nine by by taking action
now we hope that we can avert the need
for um
a more uh serious action in the future
so a second wave was a surprise
sorry i missed that kate so a second
wave was a surprise to the government
was it
no um right from the very beginning of
the pandemic um
we made clear that of course um we would
take
the measures that were necessary in
order to deal with the spread of the
infection
um and sometimes those measures would be
applied flexibly so
uh the prime minister's made it clear
that in those parts of the country where
the virus is particularly
uh fast spreading that there are there
are tighter restrictions in other parts
of the country
not so much um and also these measures
are a response to
the increase that we've seen um you keep
measures
forgive me constantly under review um
we've seen the situation in france and
particularly in spain
where um a significant increase in the
spread of the virus
has led to more people going into a
hospital and lead in particular in spain
to the number of deaths rising that's
something we want to prevent
um scientists estimate that only about
eight percent of the population
have acquired immunity as a result of
the spread of the virus so far
so that means that there are lots of
vulnerable people whom we want to
protect and because we're going into
winter
um it's also the case that the the risk
to individuals particularly
uh those who are more frail and infirm
is greater not least because the
combination of flu and covet
is particularly challenging
indeed so but you know with respect you
wanted people to go out and die now
you wanted people to go back to work we
always knew
the second wave was coming because you
made provision
for ppe etc in the last budget by uh mr
sunax so
so why why were you actively encouraging
people to go back to work
and to go out and socialize if you knew
this was coming
because again when you're dealing with a
virus like this you need to be able to
respond to changing events none of us
can predict with absolute accuracy
how the virus will spread we take steps
we take steps on the basis of the best
scientific advice
we take those steps in the belief that
they will have a beneficial effect
and we again review the evidence that's
how science works
that you you science is not something
that allows you to predict with absolute
accuracy
what the future will be science allows
you to weigh up and to balance evidence
and then to respond to events as
appropriate
yeah but your colleague um the health
secretary was basically telling us at
the end of last week and over the
weekend
that if there is a continuing rise in
the virus then
we've only got ourselves to blame
particularly young people
those young people that you wanted to go
back to work and to eat out to help out
you can understand why there's confusion
in society surely
no i i think to be fair you're um
how can i put this um taking matt's
words and putting a particular
line on them which was what do you like
what
um no i don't i can put it however you
like i've got a thick skin however you
like i've got a big skin
i understand kate but no i don't think
that's what matt was saying
um i think it's the case that the
overwhelming majority of people uh
have behaved well um you know that's one
of the the
uh things that we can take away from uh
this year that the
the british public have shown amazing uh
resilience and stoicism
self-discipline and and a sense of
community uh there have been some
uh people who uh uh haven't necessarily
played entirely by the rules
um but overall what we want to do is to
make sure that we
do the right thing the majority of
people want to the measures that we've
announced so far command public
confidence
um uh no one is blaming anyone
we're dealing with a natural phenomenon
the virus is not a
uh you know it's not a character that
you can point your finger at and blame
it is a scientific reality with which we
have to deal
how would you characterize discussions
within cabinet when it comes to what
measures should be
put in place i'm guessing you don't all
agree i'm sure you agree collectively in
the end
but there must be robust discussion
well by its very nature um uh
cabinet and cabinet committees involve
discussion but those discussions
are calm evidence-based people weighing
up different options
testing um the evidence to see uh what
would be the best response
and then calmly and resolutely agreeing
on what requires to be done who agrees
with you
well i agree with the rest of the
cabinet
yeah as i said there must be robust
discussion before you collectively
agree i hope there is um otherwise
you're just um
following the hood aren't you i'm asking
who you agree with who you tend to side
with in cabinet
well by definition um you'll have robust
discussions beforehand so
on a television program like this the
producer and the editor will discuss
things with uh the star presenter
um it might well be the case that there
are uh raised voices during that
discussion
but at the end you get a very very
professional product
there are no raised voices in cabinet
what there are clear voices articulating
um points of view which come together in
a consensus
but by definition uh the important thing
about government and cabinet government
is that uh we have an agreed position
one that's arrived at
looking at the evidence and then we
implement it
so you're all responsible really for the
poorest regions
suffering disproportionately
um well i've to take those two things
yes there is collective responsibility
in government we're all
responsible um but you're right that
there are particular concerns that
that i have and uh that the government
has um about the
you know the the structural problems uh
that our country has one of the reasons
why the prime minister
is so committed to what's called
leveling up is a recognition that
uh for a long time now wealth and
opportunity have not been equally spread
across our country
and therefore it's vitally important
that um over the lifetime of this
government we do everything we can
in order to help those in uh in
communities which have not been well
served in the past
um and there are a variety of things
that we can do investment in
the nhs is one aspect of it investment
in better public health is another
but so is investment in education and
infrastructure
and also doing more in order to make
sure that our economy rebalances and
heals
i must let you go but one final question
before i do mr gove if i may please
i'm sure that you've heard of the label
that sometimes is given to the
conservative party as the nasty party i
make no comment about that at all i just
uh refer to it i'm sure you've heard of
it
um if you cancel christmas
what do you think you'll be cool then
uh we're not going to cancel christmas
it's going to be on the december the
25th
and what will it involve will people be
able to gather together in more than
groups of six
well i uh it's by taking steps now
uh that we can i believe be in the best
possible position
uh to allow people to enjoy time with
their family
um on the most important day of the year
so it's up to us again isn't it to
behave that's what you're saying
no i'm again you're brilliant putting a
bit of shine on the ball
and trying to uh take what i say and
present it in a particular way
um but we were reminded by uh uh chris
whitty yesterday
uh that the virus is is something which
we all have to deal with
and as i say um blaming people
finger-pointing
um uh recrimination uh no but
community working together uh solidarity
yes and so i think what we should
actually be doing is celebrating the
work of people at the front line in the
nhs thanking our scientists and
uh those in authority uh with the the
the expert information
uh for uh leveling with us um and also i
just want to thank
the british people for the resilience
they've shown look these these decisions
are not
you know as i say they're not easy and
the consequences are not
happy but unless we take these steps now
then the situation would be
uh worse for everyone okay so
but you are i'm guessing hoping to have
more than your lovely wife and your two
children for christmas lunch maybe i
don't know maybe have dominic cummings
round
k if you're free on the day please come
okay you know what i might check you off
on that mr go
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed